so we're gonna get started welcome to
the Judiciary Committee subcommittee on
HB 283 relative to
um
rental application fees charged
prospective tenants
um so we are going to get started with
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
okay so we have five members of the
subcommittee and if there's anybody from
Judiciary that would also like to um
uh join with us that'd be great I'm
certainly welcome to uh representative
De Lorenzo representative Horrigan
representative Kenny and then
representative Tripp who is absent right
now so
um we are going to get started so I
first want to
call on the
Prime sponsor to lay out
the path that this bill has taken and
set the stage
is that a breed thank you Mr chair happy
to set the stage so HB 283 the original
Bill uh sought to put a cap on uh
application fees for rental units of 35
or the cost of doing a background and
credit check whichever was less this is
in keeping with a lot of similar laws on
the books in over a dozen other states
some states have outlawed application
fees outright the landlords in those
states have not gone out of the
landlording business
many states have capped it 25 35 55 in
that in that kind of range so
our housing situation the reason the
impetus of putting this in is our
housing situation has been so severe in
this state that our vacancy rate has
been near 0.6 percent is the last number
that I've heard and this has created a
situation that
unduly favors landlords so that they've
managed to make application fees
themselves a revenue stream all on its
own
um this is unlike any other industry
because in every other industry when
you're trying to get customers in you
incorporate those costs costs of
business that's free market
um and then you make up those costs
through your normal profits but uh in
our situation landlords didn't just stop
at having application fees in many
situations they would have empty units
or sometimes no units available
advertised and just bring in application
fees and with people being so desperate
they were able to not only increase
those application fees but rake in
dozens of application fees in a month
that would actually exceed the cost of
even what what they would have gotten
from a tenant renting a unit so not just
that but they've started recently doing
things like holding fees which are in
the hundreds of dollars
renewal fees which really didn't exist
before so much it's just been all all
over the place kind of predatory towards
tenants who are in a desperate situation
which I don't think is how
um our free market is supposed to work
and not unduly favoring one side of that
two-side equation it's kind of similar
to selling life rings to a to a boat of
sinking people right so anyway
um so the bill was in there was much
discussion we had multiple amendments uh
and eventually it was retained I have
worked very with the very gracious uh
chair of this subcommittee to come up
with one Amendment
um the people who have been advocating
for this
um didn't feel like that was necessarily
sufficient to address the entire problem
so we have another amendment and it is
up to you all to decide what the best
path forward is between those two
amendments or some new creative thing to
explain those amendments the amendment
and I am on both the amendment that
chair Alexander and I are on states that
first of all a landlord will disclose in
writing to a prospective tenant but for
accepting the application fee what the
criteria was successful background and
credit check would be so that tenants
are not just throwing their money on
something where they have zero chance of
being accepted the second thing is that
a landlord if they do not rent to a
prospective tenant has to return
anything beyond the actual cost so
that's an actual background check credit
check and documented administrative fees
that was kind of the nebulous part that
a lot of people took objection to
because what is to prevent a landlord
from saying that it took 10 hours at
fifty dollars an hour to process an
application
um and then finally uh it does
say that nothing in this paragraph shall
require the landlord to conduct one of
those checks or prohibit them from
accepting someone who doesn't pass those
checks and that's kind of important
because even if you put forward a
disclosure saying well this is my
minimum criteria you can still cite this
RSA saying I can still accept you even
if you don't pass this criteria but I'm
letting you know what I considered to be
acceptable
and that is for to kind of cover the
landlord but also to let tenants make
that informed decision of whether or not
to proceed forward with paying an
application fee so I think that the
Alexander Amendment the Reed Alexander
Amendment does improve our current
situation
um the Reed kutab amendment is identical
to the Reed Alexander Amendment with one
addition and that is a cap
knowing that especially the some of the
members of the Senate who would hear
this were objecting to the idea of
capping at a specific dollar amount
because that wouldn't be growth proof
we changed it to a percentage of the
monthly rental amount and after much
discussion with interested parties we
settled on seven percent so yes the
landlord has to return anything above
and beyond their costs but they can't
take in more than seven percent of the
monthly rental amount just so you can
wrap your head around that number if
it's a thousand dollar our unit it would
be seventy dollars for the um for the
check which I think the going rate right
now is 65 anyway if it's a two thousand
dollar unit the cap would be 140 at that
level and uh
there was one other piece that is
escaping me but that is so that is the
functional difference between the two
amendments
so thank you representative Reed let me
ask you
um
the amendment 2288 the one I'm not on
yes if the rent is seven hundred dollars
and it can exceed seven percent would
that even cover the cost of a background
check
I mean yes because a lot of places so
for for the most part background checks
are like 10 or 15 dollars and like I
said there's states that have outlawed
them completely because it's such a
small amount that we're quibbling over
compared to the amounts of of rent that
landlords get so yes but I would
challenge the chair to find me a 700
unit we're working on it but I I worry
that when you put something in law like
this and then the prices of everything
goes down oh my gosh please if if if the
housing market were to crash like that
then I would gladly like put in bills to
strike everything
units that are going for that all right
um any other questions representative
Reed
okay so now I'd like to call on any
other interested parties before we start
discussing this so I know Nick Norman
said he was interested in speaking
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak
there's a lot more happening on this
than I was aware a few days ago
so
it's a little confusing is to talk about
which amendment because there's three
there was an amendment that was
um representative Alexander and
representative Ellen Reed that was
putting that together so that's what I
prepared my testimony on
I also see
2286 is the one that I'm on and then two
two eight eight I see that
this 2286 has addressed a lot of our
concerns
so depending on what you're working with
where primarily this subcommittee is
representative Reed do you have another
copy of that Amendment
I
the older version that has
representative Gleason on it 422 is
another one I have but we're not looking
Supernatural
okay yeah so I think those are minor
grammatical changes two two eight six is
the one that I'm looking at okay
in terms of the idea of putting
something in to the RSA
that
housing providers could not make
application fees a profit Center
we're okay with that that concept
there's a few things in that amendment
that I looked at that would be really
troublesome
one that's still in this 2286 is
line End of Line 10 through 11. and the
criteria for a satisfactory criminal
that's very hard if not impossible to
nail down in any kind of brevity or
specificity
there are
I think what did I I'm sorry I should
I did a quick search on the internet
about
how many federal crimes there are
it's it's just
unfeasible to document with any Clarity
what's acceptable what's not
a housing provider is going to look at a
total picture
uh they're going to look at what comes
in for criminal
reports they're going to look at the
credit report they're going to look at
landlord references they're going to
make a judgment on the entire picture
they need to do that because every
situation is completely unique every
person is unique
if we were to have to put into some kind
um specific criteria what would happen
is the housing providers would make the
criteria more stringent to protect
themselves and to protect the residents
and you would in fact make it much much
harder for marginal applicants to get
approved
for instance now
there are some housing providers that
just say I will accept anyone of a
credit score over a certain number
so that's simplistic
and in some respects it makes their job
of approving application easier
it also typically throws out a huge
amount of people applying
in my office we don't do that and most
landlords that I speak to don't do that
either because
when you set that credit score bar too
high you've eliminated a large amount of
but if we have to
put in specificity I can't hardly say
that word with criminal background
checks and credit reports
you're going to find that it's just
going to make it worse and worse for
marginal applicants so in this
2 2 8 6.
if that was stricken out
I think now I'd have to review it with
my my team but I think we can accept the
rest
because all of the other objectional
some of those other objectional pieces
are in this previous amendment I looked
at it said that the
overage over the actual cost would have
to be returned to the security deposit
within 30 days
that would require in some cases
landlords to do something illegal by New
Hampshire law
in New Hampshire law a landlord cannot
accept more than a one-month security
deposit
it's not uncommon that when someone
applies for an apartment they say here
I'm very interested and I'm going to
give you the full security deposit when
I apply
if there's some overage and now we have
to return it to security that's telling
us we have to do something that's
illegal a security deposit law so if you
were looking at that previous Amendment
there's also I'm sorry there is one
other piece to this 2286 that that is
problematic
this is amending RSA
540-a colon 3. that's prohibitive
practices and security deposits
the penalties
uh that go along with that are what
landlords often refer to as the thousand
don't you think that's like extreme for
a security deposit that or an
application fee that's in the range of
25 50 typically
some I'll be here I've heard in these
testimonies that housing providers are
sometimes charging a hundred dollar
application fees personally I don't know
any landlords that are doing that
thank you
but
[Music]
um
this has to be moved either to a
different section that doesn't impose
those Draconian fees or
or say 540-a colon four
does put limitations on those fees
so you could address that section to
limit the penalties out of this thousand
yeah
also there was in a previous version
a
um part of it said
and also in any advertisement
I see that that's not included the
advertisement part in 2286 and that's
good because
to put that huge amount of documentation
of trying to Define what is acceptable
criteria or not would swap an
advertisement with
volumes of data and imagine trying to
put that on a for rent sign in a window
I mean it's an advertisement so I'm glad
to see that that was taken out and I
I think that's the major concerns and
again it's a little bit
unclear because we've got so many
different versions but if you're working
with this 22 86 with those changes that
I mentioned I can run it by my team and
thank you Mr Norman are there questions
for any questions yeah questions for Mr
Norman
foreign
is there anybody else that would like to
and just introduce yourself for the
record yeah hello my name is Julie
Smiley I um gave testimony
um the original hearing for this bill
um and I am a former employee of the
front door agency where I served as a
case manager for people struggling
um with housing crisis and
um we also served as landlords with
um over 60 housing units for low-income
individuals and the CEO of the front
door agency Maurice wearable is here
today and would like to speak to the
from the landlord perspective
um so but I want to focus on the
perspective from a renter having worked
with people for almost five years who
are struggling with the housing crisis
which I think we all know is way out of
control in New Hampshire right now it's
affecting the workforce people cannot
find stuff because people can't find
affordable housing in the state
one of the huge barriers for people and
there's many barriers this is only the
tip of the iceberg but it's important to
address is a application fees people
because of the lack of available units
renters are having to apply to 20
Apartments before they are approved
especially people with housing vouchers
um and the costs are extremely
burdensome for people struggling on a
low income they don't have the excess
funds to pay for multiple application
fees
um it is an absolute huge burden to
these families and it is also become a
profit Center for property managers who
I was reported received reports from a
number of them that received 50 100
applications for every apartment they're
accepting an application fee from every
single person that applies and ninety
percent of those applicants they don't
even run a credit check or a background
check on because they have so many they
just feasibly couldn't do it
um so I think that key in whichever
Amendment we choose to go with is
putting a cap on application fees and
ensuring that that cap is reasonable to
protect the renter
and at the same time ensure that
landlords at least their minimum costs
are met there's a cost to doing business
and we can't always expect in every
field of business that those costs are
always going to be met up front by the
consumer some of those costs are sort of
rolled in and you make your profit down
the road given that we have two sixty
thousand too few units in New Hampshire
for people to rent there is no end in
sight for the housing crisis the
landlord's income is protected
um I can't see there being an imminent
crash certainly not in the rental market
I'm not sure how they could build 60 000
units that are affordable within the
near future in the state
so the other the other key point to
mention here is the exception to the
background check
um issue that was being discussed
previously that we are asking property
managers to disclose a broad
um the broad reasons they would be
looking at within a background check is
it a past felony conviction is it a
minimum credit score and clearly within
um the language
um here it states that
um nothing in this paragraph shall
require the landlord to conduct a
criminal background check or credit
check or prohibit the landlord from
renting to an applicant who does not
pass the criminal background or credit
check so that's it's protecting the
landlord
um that we actually thought was
important after receiving communication
from a kit Lord who sent in an email and
expressed concern if they prescribe a
criteria for background checks
then how could they make an exception
for somebody say somebody that has a
felony 20 years ago but has exceptional
credit score
um and they would be willing to sort of
make an exception this covers that the
statement in here covers that and allows
for that flexibility and I I am
concerned about how
keeping the cost as low as possible so
that only the hard costs from the
property manager are covered
um even a seven percent
bill is concerning to me but if people
are only paying one fee and everybody
else gets their money refunded or ends
up not being charged a fee that may be
acceptable but I still am concerned
about lowering the bar so increasing the
minimum amount people are going to
charge
um I think those are all the points I
wanted to cover and I want to thank
everybody for their time and energies
especially you Joe Alexander and rep
read on making the efforts to address
this which is honestly such a huge issue
for people who are trying to rent
apartments in New Hampshire right now
so I'm happy to try to answer any
questions thank you Mr Smiley um are
I guess my uh
first question well my question is um
many of these rental housing units that
are available and actually some are
being built finally after many years of
no action are owned by entities which
are you know owned by other individuals
or entities who have many different uh
what multiple uh multiple uh multiple
different entities actually renting
apartments out so have you found that if
somebody's
running you know trying to find an
apartment with multiple entities that
have interlocking ownership that the
owners are charging multiple application
fees or are they just charging them one
when they're trying to looking for
multiple units owned by the same same
group
um my understanding would be you would
if it was say rare a property manager
that owns multiple
different facilities you are applying
for an apartment within a specific
facility so you your application and
your application fee would only apply to
this building over here not this
building over here does that was that
that's yeah that's that's how I thought
it was and okay not necessarily how I
wish it was but that's because I know
like in my community there's an
organization there's an out-of-state
company that bought it many properties
in my part of the state and they they
are actually a member of Nick Norman's
organization I think if you look at the
property record there's several
different
entities which are all owned by the same
company so like uh so I'm sure that's
the case in Nashville and everywhere
else too thanks
other questions representative Kenny
uh thank you for taking my question
um
in your experience can you just tell me
like the range of what you've seen
charge for application fees currently
and maybe the average
um I have seen zero fees up to 250 fees
and for 250 dollars and hold fees can be
even more than that sometimes they're
asked to put a whole entire security
deposit amount down as
um a hold fee and the average cost of an
apartment in Nashua a two-bedroom is two
thousand dollars at this point in time
um did that answer your question yeah
okay
representative De Lorenzo
take a missed it here and thank you for
taking my question
um Miss Smiley you mentioned
um that
there was an abundance of landlords
collecting fees and not renting the
units out so the landlines are making a
profit do you have any background stuff
on that any data research or anything I
don't have data or research I have
anecdotal evidence from
um clients that would call us and tell
us that they had paid fees to somebody
and then that person just disappeared
there's nothing to prevent anyone
posting an ad on Craigslist right now
saying I have an apartment to rent
getting pictures posting them up there
accepting application fees and
and given that the the rental market is
such with such a too few units and such
demand people are definitely taking
advantage of that and I think even if it
happens a handful of times it it's
something we could address by putting
limits on application fees at least in
part
thank you well I mean what would prevent
somebody from doing that is they'd be
convicted of fraud so I mean there is a
there is a court system that will
eventually settle that I get I I guess
my question is the the intent of this
legislation is to prevent landlords
housing Provisions from charging too
much and not giving the money back so
I'm asking you with this amendment that
I've collaborated with representative
do you think that the landlord should
not be able to keep
the cost the credit check the cost the
background check which some are
sometimes they're taken sometimes
they're not so if there's no background
check that money's going back to the the
applicant and documented administrative
costs
the documented administrative cost is
something that's of concern
to me because it's a very broad
statement and I am concerned about some
of the soft costs of renting I.E showing
an apartment
um hourly administrative fees for
checking credit for checking landlord
references and the other time that might
be spent could could be rolled into that
and that's my concern with the
administrative fees unless we can really
spell it out what those fees could be
but I think I think that's a difficult
thing to do I mean surely like a
landlord would not say I'm gonna get
paid fifty dollars an hour to process
this credit check and if this happened
I would think that the courts would be
like all right that's kind of ridiculous
like if this was ever adjudicated
so I think that in my experience
especially the large property management
companies that are often out of state
and have thousands and thousands of
units
are
are not looking at things from the
perspective of the tenants and it has
become a huge money-making uh
business for landlords and it's a huge
concern to me I don't think that I
understand many landlords are do trying
to do the right thing but there are also
many in any sort of business like this
that will take advantage and try to
maximize profits especially
when shareholders may be included
um just those maximizing profits issue
is a concern for me and I've seen it a
lot in working with the population that
doesn't necessarily have the resources
to take somebody to court they would be
relying on legal aid and a lot of these
people struggling uh frankly simply
focusing on what they're going to eat
for their next meal what their children
are going to eat where they're going to
sleep that night they are not going to
have the capacity to pursue a legal case
to try and get a hundred dollars two
hundred dollars back it just does not
happen they are struggling often to fill
in the forms necessary to receive their
benefits on an ongoing basis
okay
any other questions
thank you I see a lot of Merit with the
not overcharging and making a business
out of this so if if you have evidence
of any kind if you could let the
committee know about that because I'd
like to see if there's if this is a
widespread issue or as as I mentioned it
absolutely is and Murray's wearable can
probably alter also attest to it we
haven't been collecting data on that but
anecdotally I know of many people that
have been in that situation thank you
is there anybody else said wish to
testify
good morning thank you for having me
today I'm Maurice warble I am the CEO of
the front door agency located in Nashua
New Hampshire uh today I am actually
speaking on behalf of those we serve and
also as a landlord ourselves we
currently own 67 units of housing to
serve the lower income to moderate
income families in Greater Nashua area
one of our programs that I really want
to highlight today that is affected
specifically on the this bill is our
security deposit program we issue
annually nearly a hundred thousand
dollars in security deposits to families
uh this past since July of this year
we've issued 26 security deposits
totaling over forty thousand dollars to
date and of that the average has been
fifteen hundred and sixty two dollars
with the highest request being two
thousand six hundred and fifty dollars
most of the families who have applied
for security deposits for us they have
seen they've had an income of about
forty thousand dollars in annual income
for a family of three are mostly single
parents and the average a number of
Apartments they've had to apply for
before getting this apartment has been
over eight eight to nine applications
they've had to submit
some of the families have been pushed
out of current Apartments because
landlords are selling properties and
they're given 30 days to move out
obviously they're now in in dire need of
finding new places and they're putting
applications in everywhere and the fees
have been so exorbitant it's actually
set them backwards without the ability
to even come up with a security deposit
for a new apartment
these fees even at the the seven percent
amendment that was suggested at a
security deposit of 26.50 that would
still be a fee of 185 dollars that a
landlord could charge I think most of
our families could not afford that
so what I would love to see as a
landlord for us we understand that
there's a cost of doing business we
obviously want to have the most uh the
best tenants the ones that will pay the
rent every month the ones that don't
have felonies on their records and of
course doing a criminal background check
I feel is is a cost of business if
that's what we want for a tenant so for
that I I think it's important and we
would be absolutely in favor of
recognizing that and disclosing that to
our attendance so that we're not taking
funds from them to say what we are
looking for in an applicant but having
that that there's always exceptions to
every rule in the bill which this bill
clearly highlights
so so with that I would love to see
obviously the lowest administrative fee
um representative Alexander I think your
amendment is great if we could put some
type of limit on an administrative fee
whether it's one percent or two percent
that could of the total rent that could
be
um charged that would be
I think would help a lot and I don't
think the landlords would necessarily
object to that I I personally would not
um although we don't charge anything
obviously for our clients when we're
doing that also we received support from
the greater Nashua Chamber of Commerce
has submitted a letter of support of H
Bill 283 and a letter was sent to
representative Alexander on behalf of
supporting this bill because it does
affect the business economy as well in
Nashua our housing encampments are
growing
industry is finding it hard to get
Workers because of again they're
applying to several Apartments some that
do exist and some that don't so we we
appreciate any support in getting
something passed to protect everyone
involved in our community thank you any
questions thank you very much are there
any questions go ahead representative
Oregon um yes thank you um so you've
been on both sides of the uh you're
working on both sides of the landlord
tenant divide when do you and I'm sure
it uh takes a lot of time and time is
money you know to show the apartments to
the credit checks and all that but when
you're doing that are you I mean
obviously both parties benefit are you
primarily you are primarily providing
the service to the front door agency
rather than to the tenant is that
probably a correct view of it correct
yes all right thanks
any other questions
okay thank you so much for your time
is there anything anybody else I would
wish to speak on this
okay so I'm going to open it up to the
committee
um could I get some thoughts from
my friends across the aisle on what has
been said today and
give me some feedback on specifically my
Amendment uh representative Kenny thank
you Mr chairman um so regarding the
administrative costs you just got a
suggestion for language I was wondering
how you felt about that
I'm concerned with the capping it with
an arbitrary number I don't like the
seven percent number I don't like I I
think
I feel comfortable enough for lying on
the courts to really
set a precedent if there is some abuse
in in the law but I think when you have
documented administrative costs I think
a judge can see through when it's like
they're just trying to keep the money as
opposed to their trying to run their
business so I I don't like throwing an
arbitrary number in there but I think if
they can document and prove that it is
is like just time that it takes to
process it I think that is a reasonable
thing uh can I follow yep
um so you keep bringing up the court but
a good point was brought up that a lot
of these tenants would not be able to
afford the cost of going to court which
is expensive so how do you mitigate that
issue
um with what you just said well I I mean
legal New Hampshire legal assistance is
here too so I I think that in some of
these cases these cases would be brought
um on behalf of 10 other groups of
tenants tenants right organizations
things like that but I don't
I don't see
a world in which a landlord would get
away with this for a very long time
without it being like taken care of one
resident set go ahead
um so this is going to the other
Amendment because he brought up seven
percent
um does language that follows that
unless the landlord provides
documentation
um to kind of prove if if they need to
go higher than caps does that not make
you feel more comfortable with having
caps
I I'm just not in favor of the like
putting a number on it
um understood my position thank you
represent representative De Lorenzo do
you have anything
thank you Mr chair and I have a question
it's kind of glitchy
um
for the Alexander Amendment
last paragraph
um line 14.
states that nothing in this paragraph
shall require the landlord to conduct a
criminal background or credit check
check or prohibit the landlord from
renting to an applicant who does not
pass the criminal background or credit
check
and my concern is a fair housing concern
um I believe that under the fair Federal
Affair housing regulations that all
properties owners are subject to
um
require that
applicants be treated equally for
instance
you would not want to
let's say of the Smith's family in a
Jones family for the Smith family you
run credit check criminal background
check
um and landline references then you have
the Jones family
um for that family you don't do any of
that screening
um
and
you accept the Jones family but not the
Smith family or vice versa then you know
everything things need to be equal other
things being equal
that's my concern
I think and to answer your concern I
think the fair housing act really
protects the Discrimination based on
protected classes so
um
if there was any inclination that a
landlord would not rent based on
somebody's race or sex or something like
that that would be covered under Fair
Housing but I think in general the
landlord has the ability to
conduct a background check or not
um and rent to somebody or not and they
can't just not rent to somebody because
they're a different color than them
legally correct right yes so uh
representative Horrigan do you have
anything to add yes go ahead well what I
I'm somewhat uncomfortable with the
whole notion of charging people
especially people who don't have
anywhere to live and probably don't have
much money a fee
for a service which actually doesn't
benefit them directly I mean if they get
the apartment that's wonderful and
hopefully they'll be happy there but I'm
not sure why
I understand it's real cost but I'm not
sure why the landlord uh
shouldn't be paying for that out of the
rent out of the income for the business
rather than expecting you know these
people who are out on the street and
have no money to pay for it it seems
like a little unfairness involved and
also talking about the documented
administrative costs um well first of
all once again the
the service is being provided to the
landlord not to the tenant but us and
the Tenant if they're accepted we'll be
paying a very large amount of rent
probably more than they can really
afford and also many times
many times like for example the woman
who sent us the email and I guess I
won't mention their name even though her
name did get mentioned because I don't
know much about her Pacific situation
but often you know they're a sole
proprietor or they have an LLC that they
own with a few other investors so
they're they have a dual role
um they do role both as uh you know both
as an employee either of themselves or
of the entity they're running for and as
an owner so I'm not sure
I'm not sure really why they're it seems
a little it just seems a little strange
to uh expect the the applicant to
compensate compensate them for that you
know so that's uh I just find something
a little bit seems just a little bit
abusive I'm I'm I mean understand the
need maybe to have a a token a token fee
and even the seven percent of the
month's rent that seems pretty steep but
that's uh that's fair but I really don't
know whether
it's fair to expect the um the
applicants to pay for the process pay
the full cost of the process and yet
they're at their application that just
seems somewhat fundamentally unfair
although I'm certainly willing to
compromise in a token amount and maybe
even that percentage is acceptable but
um
so I feel I feel a bit uncomfortable
with some of the uh some of the language
I've been hearing from the landlords
even though I recognize you know they do
deserve to make a profit they do deserve
to make a living and it's not an easy
job I've dabbled in myself it's not
there's a lot of work involved and the
other thing
and I'm and one other thing we sort of
mentioned fifty dollars an hour is an
unfair amount and it that is certainly
beyond the capacity of the average
person who's looking for apartment to
pay but actually
if you're making you know decent middle
class income most of these landlords
hopefully they are making you know a
hundred thousand dollars a year or Mars
which divided by 2 000 hours of work a
year is fifty dollars I know I mean
I feel serious dumb saying that because
I'm paid a hundred dollars a year plus
mileage but certainly uh actually the
fifty dollars an hour I mentioned is not
excessive
in terms of what the recipient is
getting well it's certainly it's
excessive in terms of what the
applicants can afford so I
I understand this is the real cost but I
sort of feel like this should probably
be paid for out of the rent you know the
you know the rather than rather than
expecting the tenants the prospective
tenants to pay it before they even get
the apartment
um okay thank you so uh my question is
where's the committee at on
there's been a lot of landlord tenant
bills in judiciary
in my opinion this is probably one of
the only ones
that we can find a middle ground on so
I'm I'm
looking to the committee to see where
we're at on amendment 2286. I personally
don't think I could support anything
else other than that but
um with some minor changes to it
so the only change I'd make to 2286
line 10 and 11 the and the criteria for
a satisfactory criminal background check
if any
um so the disclosure of the fee
there must be a disclosure of the fee
and then
if there's a background check or
criminal check done that can get taken
out of the fee but if there's not a
criminal background check that goes back
to the applicant
minus administrative costs
so I I personally think that this solves
the problem the anecdotal problem
that we've heard from the public
and it doesn't add any or much more
undue burden on housing providers I
think that they're
um
so we have to report back as a
subcommittee to the Judiciary Committee
so if this
I mean obviously I if we took a vote
right now I think I'd be out voted so
um if there is uh any anything you'd
like to add that'd be great okay
um this is a question for you
and I don't know if you can answer it
because you don't want to speak on
behalf of the members of your caucus but
how do you think your caucus would react
to the Reed Alexander Amendment with the
changes you just said
I think with the backing of
um
housing providers and other people I
think that we could get
I mean if if all stakeholders are on
board I think that it should be
I'm representative Horgan one thing that
came up which
with the criminal background check I'm
actually reasonably comfortable with
letting that be subjective because uh
you know if
like because you know like what we heard
about the person at a low credit score
but then they were told and who knows it
was true but she believed it that this
person never uses credit cards and pays
for everything in cash and hence had no
credit history yum which I certainly
find that's certainly fine if that's
what you believe the case to be to rent
to the person rather than somebody else
had a higher credit score and also the
criminal background check you know
depends on the nature of the crime and
what you feel comfortable with uh with
having it so you might
might feel okay somebody has a
felony for something that doesn't really
necessarily make them a bad a bad tenant
versus somebody might have
what might actually be lesser charged
but it involves like violence or
something else that you find that you
just don't want going on in your units
you could it should be free to uh you
should be free to accept some people
with criminal records and some who
doesn't probably every landlord
will have a different opinion about
what their willing to risk have going on
as units and what they don't so that's
fine
okay
representative Kenny
I don't know if this is appropriate Miss
chairman but could is there any chance
that Democrats could caucus for five
record I think we would prefer the
original build but in the sense of
compromise
um
I think that online of your Amendment on
line 13 moving the word documented to
before the word background so it applies
to all background check credit check
um and then adding the word reasonable
in between and or an administrative
um so we don't CA we don't cap a hard
number but we put reasonable correct I'm
okay with that yeah and then we'd be
satisfied okay so I also want to cross
out
is representative Reed taking notes or
do we have to because she would run over
to OLS
um
line 10 after the amount of the fee
crossout and the criteria for
satisfactory criminal background check
if any
and then the other thing I want to do is
move this from A3 to A4
that is away from the penalty section I
Nick is that does that move it from the
panel does that solve your penalty
problem penalty probably
go ahead just turn your mic on for us
this way okay uh not quite
section three
um
without getting right into the or so a
or the way I remember it is
540-a colon 4 talks about what the fees
will be
so you could leave this in a colon 3
and address the amount of the fee in a
that would be the way to do it
or just move this to an entirely
different section and I couldn't tell
you what other section to put it in but
eighth a-3 defines what's prohibited and
a Dash 4 talks about exceptions to the
fees and if you don't put an exception
if you don't put in exceptions then the
fee becomes a thousand dollars per day
which of course is you know
unreasonable totally unreasonable so
they take a little bit of research
to do that language exactly right and if
you want some support on that I'm sure
that my team can easily
give you some guidance on that
okay so the the text of this language is
fine you're just now concerned about the
location of it
well
I don't know how much time you want to
give me but
um if you take out
uh documented Administration costs and
that means you're not allowing the we're
not taking it out we're going to add
reasonable that's not what I heard
I heard and take out the word documented
um move the word documented up a few to
in front of the word background so
actual cost of the documented background
check credit check and reasonable
administrative costs
but that sounds okay that's what I've
okay yeah I have to run it by my team
but that sounds okay
Okay so
to be clear the location is the only
concern here so we can move this
somewhere else you could I I don't know
how complicated that'll be it might be
logistically complicated in in the RSA
because
a colon 3 is the section of prohibited
does anyone have any language
recommendations to cover this penalties
area
I was going to say perhaps we should
talk to a lawyer at OLS or something
yeah about the appropriate section
okay
um so I'm going to ask the committee
with those changes if those are made
is everyone comfortable voting on an
amendment
like what we just discussed and knowing
that we have to figure out the proper
section I am yeah
okay is there anybody
do we need to vote we don't need to vote
is everybody okay with this change
all right so representative Reed do you
want to
take a stroll with me
okay
lovely what a great end to the day all
right is there any other business